allez la cassure vétiver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'info je sais moi qui prend ce qui
reste et s'habille tous parce que honda
important pour tout le monde
et voilà et les deux en tout cas voilà
vous pouvez arriver à andy rihs tic et
tac
on m'a dit non mais prend un rouge
brique c'est bien lisse et dégueulasse
mais le bric c'est dégueulasse et
beaucoup de ce gentil alors johnny
hallyday disait que pour réussir un
spectacle fallait soigner son entrée et
sa sortie et en télé c'est pareil c'est
pareil c'est important de bien finir sur
des missions alors je me suis intéressé
aux différentes manières de conclure les
émissions h selon l'animateur voyage
adore une fois de plus ici ça n'a rien à
voir avec les autres chaînes
en gros il ya eu chez nous qu'on voit ça
le taulier michel drucker quand il y en
voir ces carrés c'est précis c'est lui
france 2
[Applaudissements]
il un instant à dimanche
laurent romejko lui rend l'antenne mais
de façon très courtoise c'est le mec le
plus poli de télévision française bravo
on sait quatrième match de 5e à venir
pour géraud que la prochaine fois où
c'est de passer une excellente fin de
journée merci de votre fidélité encore
une forte et bien sûr ya stéphane bern
qui rend l'antenne tel un jeu de mots jo
c'est la fin de cette émission je vous
remercie de votre fidélité et je vous
dis à très bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro de secrets d'histoire alors que
sur ces huit voilà comment selanne a
fini son émission
beaucoup de gens m'ont parlé alors
beaucoup de gens m'en parlent et bret
s'est jouée cette fois il m'a dit les
gens m'arrêtent dans la rue mais
françois hollande i came c'est bon mais
je te jure que vous étiez halluciné donc
ça a dit je préfère arrêter bien sûr on
arrête là même la direction de la chaîne
maduro par urs lehmann où l'attendait
plus rien à cette émission et moi aussi
alors attention ça fait maintenant six
mois déjà qu'eric naulleau a rejoint
touche pas à mon pot s'est adressé non
six mois le bilan s'est fort ils
s'habituent à l'émission il a compris il
ne fallait pas trop s'attacher aux
nouveaux chroniqueurs mais il ya encore
du mal à s'adapter à ce que vous appelez
la dark à cécile encore d'image
ils sont trop peu tiraillé entre
admiration pour vous et consternation
département ça c'est sa jolie en vous
parce que justement d'avoir la tête à
nono tout de suite
[Musique]
eric naulleau c'est un poil à gratter du
pouvoir avec ses émissions politiques
mais il n'est pas très à l'aise quand on
se moque d'un ancien prisonnier
république justement sur la vie de ma
mère faire il est arrivé là bas il a
pris 25 kg en 105 ans il a dîné qu'on
manque total frère il est il chez bébert
loi du couscous ou très jeunes rien qu
il est secrètement amoureux d'isabelle
comme tout le monde
alors ils n'aiment pas trop qu'on a pas
de thoiry non j'étais marraine des 30
ans à d'abord
alors déjà qu'eric faire des blagues
téléphoniques c'est pas son truc mais
les jeux de mots de cyril sous le nom
d'un restaurant c'est encore moins sa
spécialité
alors c'est parti on appelle le à
tiennent donc la tienne on prend pas
[Musique]
et attention quand cyril hanouna ose une
comparaison dont lui seul a le secret
sur les césar je crois qu'on a
définitivement perdu
eric naulleau mais moi ce raid était
c'est un discours qu'on entend coller
pas les discours et c'est comme s'ils
viennent pas si t'aime pas les fesses et
tu regardes définir ce serait des foyers
lui
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
méritait bien un mec bizarre comme dans
toutes les familles ça va mieux et
qu'eric 1 non non ça va pas mieux je
vous donne plus les mots qu'ils
m'envoient oui voilà c'est pour sa thèse
et arrangez vous avez vous les donner
ouais d'accord
alors pour vous serez c'est qui la
chroniqueuse la plus sexy de tpm plus
bas c'est franchement les gars est
libellée au sia benhaim yake l'insee qui
s'appelle ces quatre styles différents
et c4 vraiment je lis ces quatre univers
d'accord les fans y élever parvenu à
lewis année va rire bien sûr et quand
pour l'instant elle va revenir je
reviendrai quand jean-michel quittera
l'émission elle tend non mais c est dans
les bacs et 4 fort franchement
magnifique
moi je vous dis voilà les quatre avaient
bien sûr mais je vais partir un mois
avec une en vacances fait qu'elle est
vite fait si la bellerie bon 12e
ouais c'est non mais c'est pas isabelle
qui émoustille le plus les gens c'est
isabelle morini-bosc que je pense qu'en
six ans d'émission alors roulé plus de
pertes que maxime gagné dans tout ça va
incroyable passé franchement chroniqueur
chroniqueuse invité j'ai même pas réussi
à compter le nombre de personnes que la
chance de se retrouver que son rouge à
lèvres la bouche durant mes dents mais
j'adore mais ces fouilles j'adore hier
j'ai passé ma sage qu'au salon de
l'étudiant
elle gagne encore plus souvent qu'elle
fait des doigts d'honneur alors j'ai
voulu faire un petit récapitulatif voici
isabelle morini décote
[Musique]
laurent gamelon fait un mètre 90 mais
cela n'effraie pas isabelle la coquine
[Applaudissements]
avec qui fait ou pas oui maison isabelle
aime tous les styles d'hommes aussi bien
ceux de m 90 que sedan m 10 isabelle
kiffe les petits mais aussi les petits
jeunes
isabelle aime ce qui est beau elle est
donc très open même pour les femmes
je ferai ça on assite à l'amour plutôt
qu'à la haine aucun homme ne lui résiste
quand elle s'attaque à une forteresse
imprenable
elle est prête à se grimer pour faire
tomber le plus bel éphèbe de la bande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et plus fort encore la chroniqueuse la
plus sexy du paf a réussi à faire
succomber mister tunisie 2002 qui ne
s'en est toujours pas remis à fnac en
moi ça va dakota j'ai kiffé et
franchement le d'anti n'est pas gênant
c'est vrai isabelle morini bosc et une
mezouza tombe j'ai un truc vous aimez et
lamouri de l'amour mais la bourse a
régalé c'est vrai avoue ben oui voila
merci les stades en vue de répondre
jeudi c'était touche pas à mon poste le
jeu de la grosse rigolade
brown qui a battu le record du nombre
des missions le plus long du monde alors
vous organiser un concours entre
chroniqueur anonyme pour intégrer la ban
de la grosse rigolade est vrai que la
star de la soirée c'est une certaine
audrey elle a tout donné malheureusement
pour elle chaque chute et tombe à plat
et vous cyril vous êtes sympa vous a
essayé de l'aider et tous ses collègues
aussi tous vos collègues ont essayé de
l'aider parce qu'il voulait tous la
pêche ça se voyait d'un côté victimes de
ce qu'on appelle désormais la chantal
ladesou août avec des moments de silence
et le flottement que j'avais jamais vu à
la télé voici la mini rigolade
la pauvre andré était assise à la place
donc maudite de chantal ladesou et
surtout d'isabelle morini bosc et là
malheureusement n'aurait dit stéphane
guivarc'h sur la coupe du monde 98 pas
une dedans donc ça un tissage alors
sénart on écoute il dit j'aimerais bien
voir 5 euros
tu peux les prêter papa est la cousine
ans 4 euros 3 euros tu fais quoi avec 2
euros tu vas t'acheter quoi un euro tu
partes avec ton frère et puis tu rentres
chez toi oui pourquoi les hommes sont
comme les pruneaux pourtant comme les
primes est exactement quoi
ben pourquoi pas tu laisses les matins
et orge à la chasse toute la journée
c'est lors d'une petite fille elle va à
l'école elle prend son char hélas la
maîtresse est dit mais pourquoi tu
prends touche à l a dit ban dès ce matin
papa est là diamant si la petite elle
part je te bouffe l'acquis et ça
continue il est parti à 3 ans en inde sa
meuf elle est tombée enceinte
il est parti à deux ans en australie sa
meuf elle retombe enceinte il par la
troisième fois à tombouctou
ça me fait leur tombe enceinte cette
année c'est monde c'est sûr je la prends
avec moi on va sortir audrey
[Rires]
ces images il faut essayer peut-on
encore alors pour finir connectu c'est
un petit résumé du prime de jeudi avec
eux une chose que vous êtes beaucoup
parce qu'à propos de mon idole absolue
qui était juste sur votre droite bouder
bien sûr là c'est le 50 secondes inside
[Musique]
et je la sors très très bien les
messieurs anglos sentiers bien
l'émission on dit souvent que vous aimez
tout le monde franchement je vois pas du
tout pourquoi les gens distant hautain
bodjona et aux tubes à moi je râlais
hotel for dogs je t'adore vraiment mais
on est on est très contents qu'il soit
là mon frère merci d'abord est avec nous
j'ai remarqué quelque chose à propos de
mon idole absolue mon ami de bouder
quand ils écoutent une blague il est
complètement hypnotisé c'est incroyable
mais vrai le pur il accélérer nos et le
poulet le double
je vais vous raconter ma demoiselle
c'est à vous tous et plus d oui
pour le plaisir on va quand même se
faire une petite blague de mohamed
benyamna plus connu sous le nom de
bouder et religieux il en afrique
hizballah défis seront safari et un
moment donné tu tombes sur un sable
mouvant et plus il descend puis guy mon
dieu sauve moi mon dieu sur moi ça les
impôts payés par hasard qui passent par
là j'ai pas besoin de votre aide
mon dieu il va m'aider écoutez monsieur
sabine et la dépouille evans au mugello
sauver le pompier revient dit donne moi
ta main je vais trouver dit normand
budget va sauver va me sauver le mec qui
meurt quand même quand elles arrivent là
haut il dit mon dieu vous m'avez
abandonné et iseult envoyé trois fois
les pompiers
[Applaudissements]